ich bin Mord bei unter anderem Amar und
laserluca und ähm
mein Problem stop stop ich kann jetzt
hole ich jetzt schon sagen mod bei
laserluca er liest nicht den Chat seine
chatkultur schrecklich und er hat kein
einziges vernünftiges Emote drin wenn du
die Möglichkeit als Mord hast irgendwie
an deinen Kanal zu kommen und da streamt
hier zu ändern damit er nie wieder
online gehen kann bitte das ja
meine Damen und Herren dieses tiktok
wurde mir den letzten Tagen einige Male
mit der Frage zugeschickt ob ich denn
mit rewinside Stress hätte
weiß ich nicht eigentlich dachte ich
nein überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun
allerdings hat mich dieses
Video gebracht denn er äußert ja hier
drei riesige Kritikpunkte an mir meinem
Content und speziell halt meinen
Livestreams auf Twitch denn darum geht's
ja hier das ist kompletter Käse ich muss
los auf dem Geburtstag ich werde jetzt
noch
[Musik]
weißt du was ich gerade bei mir im Chat
beschwert dass du dein Chat nicht liest
offen
[Musik]
hat mich gerade angerufen aber ich finde
es geil dass du auf den Anruf ignorierst
ja ich denke der meistens wenn er mich
anruft ist es irgendwie Schwachsinn das
ist fake rewi ruft einen nur an wenn er
etwas von einem will der ist nie so von
wegen ey mama was machen hey guck mal
ich mache hier eine Party kommst du rum
hey wir grillen heute im Park willst du
mit dabei immer nur so hast du heute
Zeit für einen Dreh kannst du da heute
mit dabei sein kannst du hier aushelfen
ich habe schon extra für Regen eigenen
Klingelton eingestellt bei meinem Handy
damit ich ganz genau weiß wenn es in der
Hosentasche ist und dieser klingt dass
ich mich absolut nicht bewegen werde
möchten Sie was sagen wir haben nämlich
tatsächlich
ja okay das war vielleicht Mobbing
[Musik]
ich habe ich war also sein Stream
Zuschauer zu dir rüber geschickt
[Musik]
okay hallo an alle die von rewi da sind
vor zehn Minuten hat er geredet ah ja
okay ja diese drei Zuschauer die
dazugekommen sind merkt man halt nicht
was beiseite Freunde diese ganze
Situation ist entstanden als ich gerade
mal so drei Wochen oder so auf Twitch
überhaupt unterwegs war und am
Livestream war ich bin jetzt auch kein
riesiger Streamer ich meine ich habe
durchschnittlich meine 4000 Zuschauer
Revie hat seine 900 Zuschauer im
Durchschnitt der ist ja auch schon seit
6 Jahren mit dabei wir sind beide jetzt
keine riesigen Streamer ich kenne mich
da noch nicht übertrieben aus auf der
Plattform ich muss doch erstmal checken
was ein Rate ist mittlerweile wenn ich
live bin machen wir das ja immer am Ende
dass ich so kleine Streamer einfach
Support und dann noch ein paar Zuschauer
rüber schicken ich bin heute Abend
wieder live und
Dings war das hier nur der erste von den
drei Kritikpunkten die rewi in diesem
tiktok mir gegenüber geäußert hat
äh was ist eine chatkultur also ich weiß
nicht ob ich jetzt auch hier wieder
komplett verloren bin aber ich habe den
Begriff noch nie gehört
ist das jetzt ein Front an euch
nein wir machen weiter mit dem dritten
Kritikpunkt
er hat kein einziges vernünftiges Emote
drin also das hier sind die 25 Emotes
die ich auf meinem Kanal eingestellt
habe und das sind teilweise Emotes
wirklich dabei wo ich jeweils 100 Euro
oder so für gezahlt habe die wurden von
Designerinnen gemacht die das auch für
Gronkh seit Jahrzehnten machen
also wenn du jetzt auch noch die Emote
hättest hast du auch die jetzt alle
gegen dich rewi
und das Interessante an diesem ganzen
tiktok Wahrheit dann das Monte unter
anderem auch noch darauf reagiert hat
also der größte Streamer Deutschland
an
seine Kultur schrecklich und er hat kein
einziges vernünftiges Emo drin wenn du
die Möglichkeit
also concrafter bei Twitch
ich weiß noch ganz genau da war ich
nämlich gerade live wir haben Minecraft
gespielt werden glaube ich 10.000
Zuschauer und Monte hatte dann sich
sogar meinen Stream kurz anguckt das ist
aber dieser Zusammenfassung nicht drin
also ja ich bin ab und zu live
ich weiß dass man auf Twitch wenn man
wirklich sich Streamer nennt jeden Tag
live ist ich bin eher so alle ein bis
zwei Wochen mal live aber
ich arbeite dran ja
danke danke ich habe gar nicht offen
[Musik]
oh warte ich muss mich auf Minecraft
konzentrieren schon wieder voll
vergessen dass wir live sind ja aber
sorry ich komme halt von Youtube wenn
bei mir in die Lichter an sind und hier
was läuft und da dann denke ich ich
nehme Video auf ich checke nicht das
dann dass ich dann noch also wisst Check
wahrscheinlich oder
klein angefangen aber schon respektlos
sein wenn man Stream das ist okay okay
Marcel das kann ich auf jeden Fall voll
und ganz nachvollziehen daran habe ich
auch gearbeitet ich habe jetzt den
dritten Monitor
danke es ist sehr schwer auch für mich
als Youtuber der den ganzen bumszeit 11
Jahren macht in seiner neuen Szene
irgendwie Fuß zu finden oder irgendwie
sich da etablieren zu können erst recht
wenn ich halt nicht die Zeit habe jeden
Tag live zu gehen sondern so einmal in
der Woche oder so und meistens dann halt
auch nur mit Sandra ihr wisst ja ich
habe mit keinem anderen Youtuber
Influenza irgendwie Kontakt ach übrigens
seitdem ich auf Youtube unterwegs bin
mache ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit mein
eigenes Ding ich mache meinen Content
ich mache meinen shit mein Krams
allerhöchstens mal mit Sandra aber die
kenne ich auch leider aus dem real live
[Musik]
so oder so ist es für mich aber wirklich
dann extrem schwer Fuß zu fassen auf
Twitch und sich alles halt dabei zu
bringen und das ist auch sehr komplex
deswegen Kuss Monte Dankeschön für das
Verständnis ich bin noch immer neu auf
Twitch ich werde noch immer dazu okay
hallo an alle die von rewi da sind
da fällt aber auch nicht auf beim Rewe
[Musik]
kaputt gemacht so oder so wollte es rewi
allerdings nicht darauf beruhen lassen
und hat noch mal nachgedreten ein paar
Wochen später ich habe mich zu nichts
dazu bisher geäußert weil ich dachte
komm es gibt so viele Leute die
kritisieren mich hier die machen einem
da Ansagen die kommen hier die kommen
die kommen das und es ist mir komplett
egal ich mache mein Content alles gut
wenn man sich angucken will cool hey was
geht wenn nicht verpisst euch Ende aber
wir schauen mal rein ich habe gerade
richtig schlimme Benachrichtigung
bekommen Laser Luca Wendt live Laser
fucking luca ist wirklich so dumm der
Typ hat 3000 Zuschauer liest sein Chat
nicht und kann nicht mal seine Stream
Ankündigung anpassen
[Musik]
Benachrichtigungen für die Zuschauer
sind wichtig vielleicht möchtest du
deine live-benachrichtigungen manchmal
noch mit einer Kleinigkeit ein bisschen
aufpeppen das kann ein meme sein Infos
zum Stream oder eine etwas persönlicher
gestaltete Benachrichtigung die du an
deine Zuschauer sendest mit Live
Benachrichtigungen ist das möglich okay
habe ich jetzt auch gelernt werden in
Zukunft auch kommen wir hatten noch nie
noch nie in seinem ganzen Leben das
verpackte Creator Dashboard aufgemacht
der Typ doch ich musste meine Emotes
irgendwo eine Reise danke danke der hat
noch nie das Creator Sport offen gehabt
geschweige denn den Scheiß Chat naja man
muss das Creator der Aufnahme und den
Stream zu starten also da fand ich schon
auf von den Chat habe ich mittlerweile
auch offen ja sandra hatte wir haben
schon getestet Leute ich gehe gleich auf
den Chat ein dicker dieser Mann braucht
wirklich ganz große Hilfe da muss jemand
neben ihm sitzen und die scheiß Tasten
drücken Mann
nee das stimmt nicht ich habe vielleicht
nicht so viel Ahnung vom Streaming und
von diesen ganzen Technik Sachen und so
aber ich habe mir das jetzt eingestellt
guck mal ich kann auch hier Knöpfe
drücken dann gehen meine Lampen aus
[Musik]
nicht nein sind doch bitte auf Youtube
Laser Luca bitte geh auf Youtube Stream
da er hat mehr Viewer was macht das mit
dir unfassbare Schmerzen in meinem
ganzen Körper dicker gute Besserung um
jetzt aber zum Punkt zu kommen und das
Video hier auf dem Ende zu bringen Rewe
und ich haben keinen Stress mir wurde
dieses tiktok einige Male zugeschickt
ich weiß nicht warum er so aggressiv
gegenüber meinem Stream ist ja schaut
mich an ich meine anständige Frisur oder
so bin ich allerdings gleich live ich
versuche ein paar Tipps von rewinside
hier anzuwenden wenn euch meine reaction
darauf gefallen hat wie ein anderes
Spiel mal auf mich ja Kritik habt
reagiert haben das kann ein Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weitere
Videos nichts verpassen ich